[Musique]
monsieur avant toute chose je crois
utile de nous voir préciser que si je me
suis avec vous ce soir c'est parce que
vous l'avez demandé
et afin d'éviter toute confusion
j'ajouterai que n'étant pas
politiquement engagé j'ai accepté de
nous interroger comme je les acceptais
interrogez votre adversaire s'il me
l'avait demandé
cela dit je fais partie de ces électeurs
qui se posent encore des questions en
prévision du vote de dimanche
et voici la première de celles que je
voulais vous soumettre votre concurrent
1 présentée à montceau-les-mines un
programme social dont un supporteur
monsieur mendès france dit qu'il est
démagogique en raison de son coût or que
je sache ni monsieur madame france ni
monsieur giscard d'estaing ne sont
incompétents en matière d'économie alors
qui dit vrai d'abord je tiendrai ouvert
observé que c'est parce que c'est vous
et c'est parce que vous même avez un
choix politique à faire que ça
m'intéresse
notre discussion doit être utile j'ai
besoin d'entendre nos objections et j'y
répondrai non comme je le pourrai et
j'espère aussi que ceux qui nous
écoutent en tireront profit
en effet pierre mendès france accusé les
propositions de valéry giscard d'estaing
il a dit elle sont démagogiques et cela
peut surprendre puisque il s'agit pour
l'instant du ministre de l'économie et
des finances qui n'a pas le droit d'être
démago et qu'est ce que ça veut dire
démagogue
ça veut dire promettre ce qu'on ne peut
pas tenir on pourrait ajouter promettre
pour demain ce qu'on n'a pas fait la
veille
je pense comme pierre mendès france cela
ne vous étonnera peut-être pas je le
pense parce que les propositions de
l'autre candidat sont des propositions
manifestement improvisé il fait des
découvertes tous les jours et je crois
bien qu'il a découvert avant-hier la
classe ouvrière à montceau-les-mines son
plan je n'ose à peine appeler cela un
blanc c'est une série de mesures comme
le programme de provins tirer des comme
ça sorti des tiroirs la dernière minute
son plan qui est non seulement
visé est aussi très coûteux il serait
coûteux s'il était appliqué
mais il est évident que l'autre candidat
n'y crois pas sans quoi il ne se
permettrait pas de faire cette
proposition
j'ai calculé pierre mendès france est
d'accord là dessus
entre 20 et 25 milliards et 20 à 25
milliards en une année plus que le
programme commun tant critiqué sur ce
plan par monsieur giscard d'estaing
comment frattini sur tout et ça c'est le
plus extraordinaire que toutes ces
dépenses ne sont compensées par aucune
recette aucune proposition de recettes
je dis qu'au niveau nous plaçons c'est à
dire de la présidence de la république
on n'a pas le droit de considérer les
citoyens français de cette façon ce sont
des gens sérieux
ils savent ce que c'est qu'un budget ils
savent que lorsqu'on dépense
il faut aussi avoir des recettes ou bien
on fait de la fausse monnaie j'ajoute
que les propositions de monsieur giscard
d'estaing vous me posez la question il
est normal que je pousse ma critique
improvisé coûteuses pourraient être
dangereuse dans la mesure où précisément
la croissance
le progrès est l'expansion l'emploi
risquent d'être cassées avec thé
proposition saugrenue qui n'ont ni queue
ni tête
j'observe que sur le plan leur
strictement politique
j'ai noté ici même et là document
puisque je les prie dans dans les
journaux dans le relevé des déclarations
de monsieur si un destin un certain
nombre de propositions qui viennent
d'être faites comme par exemple le refus
le le le la révision du statut des
pensions de veuves afin de permettre aux
veuves de recevoir l'arh version total
or précisément cette proposition a été
faite par l'actuel ministre du travail
monsieur gorce
il ya seulement quelques semaines avant
la disparition du président pompidou et
giscard d'estaing avait refusé j'observe
que monsieur giscard d'estaing propose
une augmentation de l'allocation minimum
vieillesse afin de le porter à 20 francs
par jour j'ai moi même proposé 21 francs
quelques jours auparavant
or monsieur edgar faure avait proposé il
y a moins de 18 mois un plan tendant au
doublement en cinq ans de la location et
monsieur giscard d'estaing lui refuse
j'ai noté encore que monsieur giscard
d'estaing propose augmentation des
allocations familiales
ce qui est bien nécessaire eh bien il ya
simplement quelques mois il l'a refusé
également monsieur edgar faure j'ai noté
qu'il a réduit de moitié les demandes de
crédits pour les hôpitaux
alors qu'il vient de proposer un vaste
plan pour les hôpitaux
j'ai noté qu'il fait des propositions
pour les anciens combattants
alors que la loi oblige le gouvernement
à décider la possibilité pour un ancien
combattant de prendre sa retraite à
partir de 60 ans naturellement avec les
avantages des 65 ans et que le décret
d'application voulu essayer par monsieur
giscard d'estaing reporte à 1977
l'application de cette mesure et en
exclu les commerçants les artisans les
travailleurs agricoles
j'observe que l'indemnisation des
rapatriés atteint des chiffres eux
dérisoire très loin de ce qui est dû à
cette catégorie de français et que
maintenant on promet tout j'ai relevé
cela exprès dans la presse et dans la
presse qui s'opposent à ma politique
j'ai donc des références sérieuses je
dis que ce plan est démagogique je ne
peux qu'approuver pire mais l'essence
soit mais vous aussi vous avez appelant
vous aussi vous fait des promesses
comment allez-vous les tenir
vous avez raison de me poser la question
je dois dire que j'ai limité mes
propositions à regret en raison de la
lourdeur de l'héritage qu'est ce que
vous voulez nous sommes dans une période
où les prix ont tellement monté si je l'
ai déjà dit mais se tient à le répéter
ici c'est ça le l'inflation si cela
continue comme cela a commencé cette
année dans le premier trimestre les prix
monteront de 10 7% cette année 17 %
c'est énorme pour les personnes à revenu
fixe pour les salariés pour l'ensemble
des gens qui vivaient modestes revenus
ne peuvent pas le supporter alors mon
plan lui il vise d'abord et ce n'est pas
si facile à tenter de freiner sinon de
stopper l'inflation la hausse des prix à
faire que
la majorité des français ne soient pas
inquiétés affolé angoissé par cette
sorte de pression ce couvercle de fer
qui s'abat sur leur pouvoir d'achat
eh bien j'ai fait un plan qui comporte
une première étape de six mois et j'ai
veillé à financer mes dépenses
naturellement j'ai prévu d un certain
nombre de dépenses sociales
c'est normal et nous avons du rattrapage
à faire il ya des injustices trop grave
qu'il faut réparer tout de suite donc
des mesures immédiates je vais réciter
elles sont au nombre de sept par exemple
j'ai prévu l'augmentation immédiate dès
la semaine qui suivra
mon installation à la présidence de la
république en conseil des ministres un
certain nombre de décisions comme
l'augmentation du smic à 12 100 francs
par mois sur la base des 40 heures
c'est indispensable chacun sait bien on
ne peut pas laisser des millions de gens
dans la misère alors qu'il travaille
j'ai prévu des mesures pour l'allocation
minimum vieillesse
je les ai dit tout à l'heure 21 francs
25 par jour mais tout de suite ce sera
décidé dès la semaine qui suivra et non
point renvoyée aux calendes grecques
un an comme le fait monsieur giscard
d'estaing mêmes dispositions pour mes
grands handicapés 21 francs 25 par jour
des dispositions comparable pour les
jeunes à la recherche d'un premier
emploi vous imaginez la situation de ces
jeunes
j'imaginais la situation de leurs
parents ils ont des diplômes ils peuvent
travailler ils n'ont rien
cela brise bien des jeunes foyers cela
crée le désespoir et même souvent la
colère contre notre société
eh bien j'ai prévu 800 francs par mois
c'est-à-dire les deux tiers du smic
et tout cela sera décidé tout de suite
de la même façon je pense que on doit
relever les allocations familiales j'en
ai parlé de quelle façon et bien en
suivant la hausse des prix nous avons
déjà depuis quelques temps constaté que
les allocations familiales avait pris
beaucoup de retard par rapport à
l'augmentation des salaires laquelle
l'augmentation des salaires a pris du
retard par rapport aux prix et il en
avait pris depuis très longtemps par
rapport à la production ce qui veut dire
que les
travailleur ne reçoivent pas les fruits
de la croissance dont on parle si
souvent de la même façon je voudrais
indiquer que je m'adresse aux épargnants
et que les livrets à de caisse d'epargne
à compter du moment où il y en aurait un
par famille
dans le cadre du plafond actuel devrait
être indexé sur la hausse des prix
vous avez des millions de gens qui
économisent ils ont raison d'économiser
il s'inquiète lui aussi et c'est très
utile en état c'est très utile à la
nation
or ils perçoivent un taux d'intérêt de
6%
quand les prix montent de 14 case
peut-être 17%
ils sont volés j'estime donc qu'il faut
indexer c'est-à-dire aligner le taux
d'intérêt sur la cause du prix pour
l'instant
jeudi 15 % enfin vieille revendication
fondamentale que chacun comprendra
l'échelle mobile des salaires mais cela
est déjà admis dans beaucoup de milieux
voilà pour mes mesures sociales et vous
me posez la question mais ça va coûter
cher oui j'ai fait le calcul cela
coûtera sur le plan du budget de la
nation environ 9 milliards de francs
cela coûtera aussi mais j'y viendrai il
s'agit des mesures économiques que je
n'ai pas encore abordé mais je vais
faire un panorama du coup 3 milliards
aux entreprises lorsque j'aurai examiner
de quelle façon
enfin il s'agit du smic gevrey au fond
approfondir la discussion sur ce sujet
mais je craindrais qu'on ne connaît pas
le temps car nous n'avons que 25 minutes
donc l'ensemble des mesures que je
prends pèseront pour 9 milliards sur le
budget y compris la réduction de la tva
dont je parlerai tout à l'heure et pour
3 milliards sur les entreprises étant
bien entendu qu'à travers le smic
j'observe que dans beaucoup
d'entreprises
il y a déjà des dispositions prises pour
que les 200 francs soit atteint et
d'autre part si certaines entreprises
utile ont des difficultés je prévoirait
la disposition d'un crédit sélectif
comment financer cela 9 milliards les
excédents budgétaires existe on dira
mais alors ça c'est un phénomène de
bonne gestion
vous approuvez monsieur giscard
d'estaing pas tout à fait dans la mesure
où c'est un budget excédentaire parce
qu'il ya l'inflation comme monsieur
giscard d'estaing reçoit les recettes
ce sont des recettes gonflé et vous fais
part l'inflation c'est à dire le
résultat d'une politique fâcheuse mais
enfin il y a je le crois monsieur chaban
delmas m'avait dit dans un débat 14 ou
15 milliards disponibles
eh bien je pense qu'il est nécessaire
pour réaliser ces mesures sociales
d'utiliser 9 milliards je reste donc à
l'intérieur d'un budget rigoureux ou
laid ressources compense les dépenses et
c'est cela le refus de la démagogie
je tiens véritablement insisté là dessus
il n'est pas question pour le
responsable que je suis d'engager le
gouvernement de la france à agir
autrement que comme le ferait un chef de
famille qui se voudrait honnête et
qu'ils n'iraient pas dépenser comme ça
en douce en le dissimulant à sa femme un
certain nombre de petits plaisirs tandis
que elle croit réel que le budget
équilibré pour payer les livres de
classe les vacances des enfants
enfin tout ce qui fait la vie d'un foyer
naturellement il faut que des mesures
économiques viennent équilibrer ces
mesures sociales puisqu'il s'agit de
lutter contre l'inflation dont on ne
parle pas monsieur giscard d'estaing
j'en suis tout à fait stupéfait
l'inflation c'est le mal de notre temps
sans doute est-ce mal internationale
mais tout de même nous bientôt 17 %
l'allemagne 10% ce qui veut dire que
notre commerce extérieur et basculer je
le dirai tout à l'heure si nous en avons
le temps savez vous que on nous
dissimule les chiffres du déficit du
commerce extérieur du mois d'avril
je crois que ce déficit de l'ordre de 2
milliards ce qui veut dire qu'on va
atteindre 25 milliards de déficit dans
l'année il faut absolument se redresser
et bien moi j'ai prévu décisions
difficiles croyable pour un homme
politique
le un contrôle des prix très sévère
naturellement temporaire trois mois et
sélectif ne s'agit pas de faire tout et
n'importe quoi sur les prix industriels
est essentielle
on essayait de me faire dire ce que je
n'ai pas dit en particulier sur les prix
agricoles comment respules dire d'abord
les prix agricoles ils sont fixés à
bruxelles ensuite peut-être ne savez
vous pas moi je passe mon temps dans mon
département qui est un département
essentiellement agricole mais les
éleveurs notamment les éleveurs de
bovins connaissent des pertes terribles
à la production quelquefois même le
quart de la valeur de leur cheptel une
peuvent plus investir
il faut qu'ils payent les prix
industriels de plus en plus cher leurs
engrais leur leur matériel agricole
donc pas question de bloquer les prix
agricoles et surtout pas la production
puisqu'il faudrait au contraire les
élever les enfants
indiscutablement sur les petits les prix
industriels je répète ce que j'ai dit
d'autre part je prévois une baisse de la
tva une réduction aux taux zéro sur les
prix sur les produits de première
nécessité ou de consommation courante
on en a beaucoup discuté avec monsieur
giscard d'estaing cessons cette dispute
en tout cas il s'agit de produits comme
le lait comme le pain comme la viande de
porc ou d'autres choses qui sont
nécessaires à la vie quotidienne la
ménagère je vous prie de le croire celle
qui m'écoutent pour l'instant il
comprend ce que je veux dire
le coût environ 3 milliards sur six mois
6 milliards sur un an mais comme il
s'agit d'un prix comme comme il s'agit
d'un plan de six mois vous l'avez déjà
compris que cela s'insère dans
l'ensemble du coût budgétaire que j'ai
déjà précédemment indiqué et puis la
grande mesure la plus importante
peut-être consistera à lancer un emprunt
et un emprunt de 10 milliards ce qui est
important indexé sur la hausse des prix
c'est à dire que les porteurs auront une
certitude de de rentrer dans leur argent
pour le moins et 703 s'adressera aux
petits porteurs il ne sera plus comme ce
qu'on a fait ces temps derniers qui
étaient uniquement souscrits par des
banques ou des grandes sociétés fait
petits porteurs cet emprunt a pour objet
essentiel d'essayer d'éponger une grande
partie de la masse monétaire qui à
l'heure actuelle elle
10 notre capacité économique et
aggravent les risques d'inflation et
d'autre part il a pour objectif non
point de compenser d'éventuels déficits
budgétaires comme on me le dit encore
une fois mensongèrement mais en vérité
de lancer de grands travaux et donc de
permettre le plein emploi de développer
notre capacité industrielle
voilà des mesures économiques qui
compenseront les mesures sociales et qui
permettront d'en je le crois dans une
proportion très raisonnable et dans les
six mois qui viennent non seulement deux
cas c'est l'inflation mais aussi de
porter la croissance aux environs de 5%
et dans l'immédiat c'est à dire dans les
quinze jours qui suivront l'élection de
répondre aux besoins des catégories les
moins favorisées
voilà mon plan économique et social il
est beaucoup plus modeste que je ne le
voudrais mais je suis bien obligé de
tenir compte du triste héritage que
j'aurais assumé gamme question jeu est
ce que vous avez l'intention de lancer
votre emprunt avant ou après avoir
nationalisé les banques d'affaires et le
crédit le problème de la nationalisation
ne peut pas se poser dans l'immédiat
attention que ce soit pas interprétée
comme un recul car cette nationalisation
de neuf aux industriels et du crédit qui
me paraît absolument nécessaire qui a
commencé d'être entrepris par le général
de gaulle en 1945 ne peut intervenir que
par la loi c'est à dire que cela ne
dépend pas de la décision du conseil des
ministres ni de la volonté du président
de la république mais du vote du
parlement à compter à partir de là cela
rejette en effet ces dispositions à plus
tard étant bien entendu qu'elles seront
prises aussi dans le cadre de la
situation telle qu'elle sera examinée et
des équilibres indispensables
je constate toutefois qu'il n'avait pas
parlé parmi les mesures qu'il comptait
prendre de l'impôt sur le capital au web
sur l on me dit ça parce que vous êtes
sensible à ce que l'on répète par toro
sûrement vain puisque vous êtes vous
mêmes électeurs ça vous intéresse est un
peu tôt vous possédez peut-être un petit
bien vous dit si on m'apprend thune
party ça me fait pas plaisir
c'est un déborde attaques les plus rudes
contre mes propositions
seulement voilà il faut parler plaire
qu'est ce que je demande
je demande pour plus tard je veux dire
quand le parlement pourra en décider
cela non plus n'est pas de mon ressort
ni du ressort du gouvernement je demande
un impôt sur les grandes fortunes alors
aussitôt qu'ils ont dit à l'impôt sur le
capital
le jeune cadre qui vient de bâtir sa
maison c'est qu'ils s'inquiètent en se
disant on va me prendre une partie de
mon capital ont pas m'imposer 5000 6000
e dix mille francs
tout cela c'est une mauvaise
plaisanterie il s'agit d'atteindre des
grandes fortunes qui se sont édifiées
et cet impôt sur le capital sur les
grandes fortunes
il existe déjà dans des pays où le
capitalisme est roi pensez aux états
unis d'amérique où il ya l'impôt sur les
grandes fortunes penser à l'allemagne de
l'ouest
pensez à la suisse alors pense que c'est
vraiment faire une politique très
réactionnaire que de refuser cet impôt
là je pense aussi que c'est une tactique
électorale qui n'est pas honnête que de
penser que nous pourrions que je
pourrais porter atteinte à la propriété
gagné par le travail par l'effort et par
l'intelligence de mes concitoyens je
suis moi-même petits propriétaires et
croyez moi j'y tiens je suis observé
vers un oui nous avons posé ces
questions et je pense bien entendu dire
que j'aurais l'intention de bloquer les
comptes courants enfin soyons sérieux
bloquer les comptes courants et pour
quoi faire
j'ai entendu dire que je voulais
supprimer le régime des retraites
complémentaires pour les cadres je m'en
suis expliqué déjà hier lorsqu on fait
rentrer avec le régime général
oui mais n'est ce pas le projet de la
gauche consiste naturellement c'est une
perspective lointaine ne peut pas se
décider comme ça consiste à décider
qu'il faudrait que tous les salariés est
une retraite correspondant à 75% du
traitement de leurs dix meilleures
années dix meilleures années de carrière
ça c'est un objectif très louable la
preuve c'est qu'actuellement des cadres
avec le régime général et le régime
complémentaire les mieux placés ne
dépasse pas 67 ou 68 %
bon ça c'est un objectif ces lointains
ne tue un mort si on pouvait le faire ce
serait bien mais tant que cela ne sera
pas fait il n'est pas question j'en
donne l'assurance solennel il n'est pas
question de toucher
régime complémentaire des cadres et tous
ceux qui disent le contraire font une
opération électorale de mauvais aloi qui
rabaisse notre débat car voyez vous vous
le sentez bien depuis la première minute
à quel point j'éprouve la noblesse du
combat dans lequel je suis engagé je
souhaiterais vraiment que monsieur
giscard d'estaing veuille bien faire
comme je le lis a vite c'est à dire que
c'est un débat qui doit élever la
conscience des français et leur
permettre de choisir gravement les
intérêts de la france puisque vous
parlez de bva monsieur j'ai noté qu'au
cours de votre face à face avec monsieur
giscard d'estaing vendredi dernier à la
télévision
il vous a posé à au moins deux reprises
la question suivante qui était sur le
banc de mémoire comment comptez vous
vous y prendre pour revaloriser le front
comme vous le prométhée vous n'avez pas
répondu mais j'ai pas répondu parce que
ça a été posée tout à fait à la fin et
qu'il m'était difficile de revenir sur
des sujets économiques alors que nous
étions déjà engagés ou art direction
d'avoir discuté et de politique
étrangère et de politique générale et
j'ajoute que j'ai fait une conférence de
presse là-dessus dès le début de ma
campagne que je pensais que monsieur
giscard d'estaing avait une l'obligeance
devaient goûter
qu'est ce que je veux dire par là j'ai
déjà parlé il ya quelques instants du
déficit de notre commerce extérieur qui
s'aggrave
il faut absolument tenir bon et tenté de
défendre le travail français la monnaie
représente le travail des français et il
faut que le travail français se
revalorisent dans la compétition
internationale
or c'est la débandade on a déjà lu il ya
quelques années on a dévalué il ya
quelques mois avec le flottement du
franc pendant ce temps l'allemagne à 4
fois réévalué eh bien il faut avoir une
volonté et décidé de défendre le franc
est de dire que dès les circonstances le
permettront naturellement ça ne se
décide pas trois mois d'avancé du pastel
jour je ré évaluerait le from il faut
avoir une volonté il faut faire comme
l'ont fait nos anciens quand ils se sont
accrochés à la marde
ils ont dit et bien maintenant on lâche
plus on tient le terrain on s'accroche
afin de repartir en avant et non point
en arrière ma volonté et les de
revaloriser le franc est de permettre
son
pour au sein de ce qu'on appelle sont
des langages de techniciens le serpent
communautaire c'est-à-dire la communauté
des l'ensemble des pays en dehors de
l'italie de l'ensemble des pays du
continent de l'europe des neuf reste que
je crois nécessaire
c'est une volonté nationale ça nous fera
payer d'ailleurs moins cher nos
importations et ça servira et tous ceux
qui disposent à l'heure actuelle de
petits et moyens revenus
une dernière question je vous avais dit
au cours de la campagne ou plutôt votre
adversaire vous a dit vous êtes un homme
du passé vous avez répondu le passé
c'est vous alors si l'on vous suit l'un
et l'autre nous allons retrouver lundi
avec un président quel qu'il soit qui
sera un homme du passé et avec dans
l'opposition à peu près 50% de français
qui seront eux-mêmes des hommes du passé
puis qu'ils auront voté pour un homme du
passé qu'est ce que vous pensez de cette
situation pour répondre à votre question
il ne s'agit pas de l'état civil des
deux candidats moi je suis né en 1916 le
26 octobre si on veut le savoir
et quand j'écoute de monsieur giscard
d'estaing et quand je vois ceux qui
l'entourent j'ai quelquefois
l'impression qu'il est né avant 1789
si nous avons aujourd'hui sur le plan
d'état civil près de dix ans de
différence croyez moi ça va vite
ce n'est pas le problème soyons sérieux
le problème était de savoir quelles sont
les forces politiques et sociales
économiques et aussi qu'ils supportent
ou qui soutiennent nos candidatures et
bien moi j'observe tous les sondages le
démontrent qu'ils sont d'accord
là-dessus depuis le premier jour que ma
candidature a derrière elle ou autour
d'elle lançant des forces de la jeunesse
et l'ensemble des forces du travail et
de la production
c'est 2 un événement colossal dans notre
histoire
cela représente une valeur dynamique qui
de toute façon se projettera dans
l'avenir prochain je suis donc un
candidat soutenu par les forces de
l'avenir et c'est la seule chose qui
m'intéresse
du côté de monsieur giscard d'estaing je
ne dis pas que tous ceux qui ont voté
pour lui et 32% du premier tour tous
ceux qui voteront pour lui le 19 mai
soit des forces réactionnaires
non pas du tout je pense simplement
qu'on les trompe et qu'ils ne savent pas
encore c'est pourquoi je veux
m'expliquer y compris devant les
électeurs qui n'ont pas voté pour moi et
j'ajouterais y compris pour les
électeurs qui ne voteront pas pour moi
mais ce sont mes frères
ils sont français comme moi et je leur
doit des explications
eh bien je dis que ils risquent d'être
trompés par des petits groupes d'une
société privilégiée dominante qui vient
de loin dans notre histoire qui
représente les anciens châteaux forts
les dominations des sociétés
multinationales
la domination des privilégiés et je dis
que c'est ça le passé et qu'il faudrait
en finir dans la fraternité
naturellement sans vouloir punir ni
frappé personne mais aussi dans la
justice
[Musique]